everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem
subsets so we are given an integer array
nums and all we need to do is return
every single possible subset that we
could create
from the input nums and we do not want
to
include any duplicate subsets so what is
a subset well let's say we have
one two three as our input one subset of
course would be
one right by itself another subset would
be two by itself
we could do one two together now what
happens if we do
two one right we just swap the order
does that
count as a different subset or is that
the same
as this subset well they're the exact
same we don't care about the order this
is not a permutation
this is a subset so it's not a
permutation
it's a subset so we do not want to
include
duplicates and this counts as a
duplicate we're not going to include it
and 3 is another subset 1 3 2
3 1 2 3 the original input
is technically also a subset and we also
don't want to forget the empty subset so
no matter
what we're given an empty subset is
technically a subset of this
as well so if we want to create all the
subsets from this input we have a choice
for
every single element so for this one
we have a choice of include the one in
our subset
or not include the one so we get an
empty subset right so we have that
choice
and we have that choice for every single
input element so in total we have two
choices here
two choices here and two choices here so
this is going to be
8 or in other words 2 to the power of n
where n is the size of our
input right so this is the number of
subsets
and we don't want the number of subsets
we actually want the subsets themselves
so how long could a subset be right well
we could have a subset one two three
right the size of our input
we could also have subsets that are
smaller right like one two
maybe two three so as you can tell
this is not going to be an efficient
problem to solve we have this many
subsets
and each subset could be up to length n
so the worst case time complexity of
this problem is going to be
n times 2 to the n regardless of
how efficient we make it because given
the constraints of this problem we don't
want the number of subsets we want the
subsets themselves
we have to make it inefficient so with
this in mind we can just
jump straight into backtracking which is
the brute force way of solving this
problem but it's also
pretty much the most efficient way so
like i said
for each of these elements we have a
choice so i'm going to draw the decision
tree
so first we can choose to add one or
not add one and that will give us two
subsets one subset with just one
and one empty subset so along
this path we can decide now do we want
to add two or
not add two so with one decision we will
add two and the other decision we won't
add to
so we'll get one two as one subset and
the other subset will just be
one by itself and we can actually repeat
that
on the right subtree for two so we can
decide to add
two to this empty subset or we can
decide
to not add two to the empty subset in
which case we'll get
a subset with two by itself or we'll get
the empty subset again right
this is where we're just not adding
anything and lastly
we can decide whether we want to add
this 3 or not
so if we add the 3 to this subset we'll
get
1 2 3. if we don't add the 3
then we will remain as 1
2 and we can repeat that decision over
here
and that's basically what i'm gonna do
now right repeat that decision for every
single one of our like you can call them
nodes or you can call them leaf nodes
that's just what we're doing
so if i add the three here we'll have a
one three
if i do not add the three here we'll
have the
one by itself so you can kind of see
these are
four unique subsets right now let's
build the rest of the four from over
here
so i have the choice do i add three or
do i
not add three to this subset if i do i
will get
two three if i don't i will have
two by itself and you can see these two
subsets are
different from the subsets over here
these are still unique
and lastly we can choose to add three
to the sub to the empty subset or we can
choose
not to add three to the empty subset in
which case
we'll get a single empty subset now you
can see
we keep multiplying by two right so here
we had a one we had one
we we multiply by two now we have two
subsets over here right we go down again
we multiply by two now we have
four subsets over here right then we go
down one more time multiply by two we
have
eight subsets and they're all unique
this is our result this is what we're
building with this problem
this is backtracking now if you want to
know how to do this backtracking
solution in code
let me show you right now so let's do
this with backtracking so we're going to
have
a result list which we're going to add
these subsets to
and i'm gonna do this with uh
backtracking depth first search
and i'm going to write this function
inside of this function
so that we don't have to pass in this
variable or this variable into it
we'll just have access to it by default
but i'm going to pass an i which is the
index
of the value that we are making the
decision on so
you know we had one two three so
initially i'm going to pass an
index zero for this one and you know
this will be index one this will be
index 2 that's going to tell us
whether we decide to add 3 or not add 3.
so this i will tell us which element
we're currently
visiting and so we know that the base
case for this will be if
i happens to be out of bounds so if it's
greater than or equal
to the length of our input we know we're
out of bounds
and in that case we can just return now
what
what like data structure am i going to
use to build each subset i'm going to
have an array and i'm going to allocate
it
outside of the function so that we have
global access to it inside of
this function right so let's say cur
let's actually call it subset
let's say that it has the subset that we
currently have if we ever reach the base
case we know we've gotten
past our leaf node so what we can do is
add that to our result
and i'm also going to add a copy of the
subset because
it because the way it works in python
and in most most languages
this subset is going to be modified
right so we know we have two decisions
so this is the decision
to include nums of i so this is like our
left decision that i showed you in the
picture right so what i'm going to do is
to the subset i'm going to append
nums of i and then i'm going to
recursively run
depth first search on the next element
so i plus
1. so this is going to be like the left
branch of our
decision tree and this is going to be
the decision
not to include nums of i so basically
we're skipping numbers of i so how am i
going to do that i'm going to take the
subset
and just pop the element that we just
appended and then i'm going to
recursively run depth first search
uh i'm basically going to do the same
thing so these
two function calls while they look the
exact same they're going to behave
slightly differently because for this
recursive call
it's going to have a different subset
given to it
and this recursive call is going to have
an empty subset given to it so now the
only thing left for us to do
is call our function of course we're
going to pass
an index 0 that's the first value and
then we can return
our result so as you can see it is of an
efficient solution
luckily for us the order that we have
our subsets in the result doesn't matter
so for example if we had an empty
subset and we had one that's the same as
if we returned
one and the empty subset right like the
order that we put the subsets in
doesn't actually matter but again i hope
this was helpful if you enjoyed
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon